one thing I really miss about New York
is the Macy's Thanksgiving Day Parade
that was one of my favorite things that
happened here every year I would go but
I always had one criticism why are the
balloons always things for kids like
Pikachu Ronald McDonald
I think the balloons the poor a balloon
should be New York themed I really do
it's a big New York event I believe that
in my heart no I that's the thing I'm
most passionate about in this lifetime
so I came up with some New York themed
balloon designs can I share them with
you if they work out instead of Big Bird
instead of Big Bird how about this New
York staple Times Square Elmo right
there you see you snow
you smell him before you see him you
know here's another New York blue and I
think would be great a vandalized city
bike I think that would be fantastic
check this one out the New York Giants
current one and seven record
it's a really angry guy in the audience
here's my point of doing
that guy lost his [ __ ] on that joke he's
like what
boy have my facts wrong sir here's a
Macy's theme balloon it's a discounted
bottle of their pitbull Cologne yeah
here's another New York balloon I'd love
this it's a pigeon and a cockroach
fighting over a cronut
hey now that guy and I are friends again
alright he's like that's okay I also
thought since I'm back in town the
Thanksgiving Parade would maybe have a
Conan balloon you know I just thought
maybe so true story true story I ran
this idea past Macy's they gave me a
very quick no okay
Macy's also pointed out that the
balloons take a year to build an entire
year I decided to make my own balloon
anyway and guess what my balloon took a
week to make one week it was easy here's
what we did we went out we really did
this we went out and we bought one of
those New York City's strike rat
balloons you know what I'm talking about
yeah you can buy those anyone can buy
those I bought one and we just added
Conan features to it it's actually
outside the theater right now ladies and
gentlemen check out the Conan Strike R
at Macy's Thanksgiving Day Parade
balloon
[Applause]
[Music]
it's a little like a prominent
politician as well but anyway and guess
what Macy's cuz I know you're watching
you heard the crowd go crazy you're
excited my balloon also my balloon also
comes with a special performance by
American Idol and Broadway star Justin
Guarini check it out
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's great
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
you